let's see let's check in with our caller
from country code 44 country code 44
who's this where you're calling from
hello yeah that's you yeah i'm i'm a
student in edinburgh now just in the
middle of a project but I guess want to
call in I'm a first-time caller I I've
really been interested in American
politics for so long now and to be
honest with you I used to look down on
people that didn't partake in elections
myself but with all that's happened in
this Democratic primary and and stuff
the people I look down on now is the
people has actually bothered to take
part in these these elections mmm you
know I never understood why people
didn't vote but now I do you know Bernie
Sanders what what the DNC did to him in
terms of the way they reorganized
themselves you know to reorient around
Biden the way all the candidates have
dropped out the organized nature of of
this was really just got to me and you
know I just don't understand how people
can look at Biden and think you know
yeah I mean there's no doubt that Biden
is better than trunk nobody's doubting
that for one second but what happens
after you know a Biden presidency you
know are we just gonna assume that Biden
is set up to you know a better future
for America to be honest with you the
way American history suggests right
after Biden there's just gonna be
another trumpet you know I don't get it
I mean I don't agree I don't I don't
believe that that's at all a guarantee I
think about it I think about it this way
imagine you know a large cruise ship and
you have one place you want it to go and
Republicans have a different place that
that they want it to go for me the
perfect analogy which is an
incrementalist analogy rather than an
acceleration is than
is the earlier you turn towards your
destination the less erratic your future
turns need to be and we've all seen
these examples of you know of a small
change in the angle at which you leave
Boston could get you to Scotland or it
could get you to Morocco and so my view
is not one where every election needs to
be assessed as what is the setup for the
subsequent election and what is it
likely to lead to what I know is another
four years of Trump steering the ship
gets us much further than where four
years of Biden gets us in either case at
the end of the next four years we're not
going to be where we want to be but we
will be closer with Joe Biden and for me
it's that simple so I think we just have
a fundamental disagreements of the
principle here yeah but um I I look at
you know the Obama campaign for instance
interim he Kieran as a poppy face
basically a populist in 2008 for all
intents and purposes you know it
especially when you juxtapose him
against somebody like you know Clinton
and I agree so I agree that you know
Clinton Obama ran on a populist ish sort
of campaign but really Obama I think ran
on a you know sort of pragmatic
center-left you know more open to
progressive ideas than someone like
Clinton but I don't know that I would
primarily characterized Obama's campaign
as populist yeah but you know um what
I'm trying to say is when you look at
the last three elections yeah and you
look at you know that the sort of people
who did the people that lost the last
three elections you know John McCain
Mitt Romney Clinton you know these are
stablishment candidates you know these
are people that you know have a have
made a name for themselves in politics
for such a long time before they
sorry to run and you look at Obama and
Trump you know relatively speaking they
were nobody's can argue with that quite
clear at this point that the American
people they want something new they
don't want more of the same and my worry
is that Biden who you know people look
at Biden and go well I would rather give
Trump another four years ridiculous that
may seem some people may actually say
that so here's here's my father he's my
understand what I understand what you're
saying here's why I disagree with it
number one Donald Trump is such a
different political animal than anything
we've had before and remember Obama was
a was a new US Senator but he was a u.s.
senator he was not you know some
privileged real estate dude from from
New York City so so Trump is in a league
of his own I believe that listen we'll
see what happens in November I believe
that Joe Biden has a reasonable shot at
winning we don't know what will happen
because Donald Trump has been so
outrageous that people are looking for a
return to something more familiar now
that's not a defensive centrist politics
and I hope that Joe Biden if he wins you
know we have to do everything we can to
pull him to the left in every
opportunity but I actually think that
the circumstances are so unique that
going back to something that feels more
normal is exactly what a lot of people
want yeah and just just to add because I
kept hope hope to well I don't believe
in God but hope to whatever that's yeah
come 20/20 21 the Senate hopefully I
don't know how you see that happening
but the Senate somehow just finds a way
to become blue hopefully yeah yeah I've
done a bunch of analyses on that so I
won't go over the details but it's
certainly it's possible it's your battle
but it's but it's possible listen I
really appreciate the call from Scotland
yeah thank you thank you very much all
right take care hope to hear from you
again